three decades after that classic early
90s trash fire monstrosity Nintendo was
like okay
we will give a mulligan another Mario
Brothers movie We're allowing it here's
hoping for a Legend of Zelda movie and
Metroid also but here we go Mario
[Music]
so the Super Mario Brothers movie is an
adaptation of the Super Mario Brothers
game for the big screen I feel like
that's all the setup you need right
there it's an animated feature by
illumination entertainment the plot is
very much the plot of a Super Mario game
Mario and Luigi go down a drain go to
this magical world Bowser's causing
problems he needs to be stopped want to
touch on the voice acting here also
because that's where the apprehension
was like oh Chris Pratt it's Mario's hmm
no one seemed Blown Away by Chris
Pratt's Mario iteration in the trailer
but he really works in this movie in
fact most anyone in this movie is pretty
well cast they do a good job in this
movie in a very clever way addressing
Mario sounds like this and that's
totally cool but it's not just Mario
Charlie day is Luigi is next level
perfect Anya Taylor Joy is peach Keegan
Michael key is Toad Seth Rogen is Donkey
Kong going on and on here but the point
is when you're watching the movie and
you're watching the voices play out in
front of you you can't help but think is
there anyone else I would cast who would
be better in these roles
no not for my money I can't think of
anyone Jack Black as Bowser also great
there's actually some humorous moments
with Bowser where he's just pining over
Peach and you gotta think well yeah he
probably does do that in his off time
it's part of the humor of the movie
because this is an animated feature for
children there is one small role in the
movie A support character that I didn't
feel the voice fit as well I don't know
if people know this character's in the
movie but I could have gone for the
character sounding older and crankier
and the animation is great this movie is
kind of extraordinary actually the
metric for that I don't know if it's
even accurate but it's water effects
water particles when anyone's in water
for some odd reason I look at that I'm
like okay that's how good the animation
is in Super Mario Brothers movie it's
actually pretty incredible Easter eggs
and references oh yeah they're all in
here and they start out pretty early too
the thing that makes it different for
this movie is there are a lot of movies
out there that just rely on Easter eggs
and references this never felt like
member berries it just it felt like a
celebration it felt fun it would have
felt weird if they didn't have them so I
enjoyed them when I saw them I had fun
when they caught my eye my fellow Super
Mario Brothers Super Show fans you'll
know it you'll hear it and Brian Tyler's
musical score for this film I felt was a
great way to take classic Mario tunes
and adapt them for live actuals not live
action it's animated but you know what I
mean adapt it for the big screen change
it up a little bit to fit the action
sequence that's going down as it's going
down but still maintain the core of the
theme that you're playing off of I
thought it was really well done and what
a project you know that must have been a
lot of fun being like
I have these classic tunes that I get to
tweak with and adapt to the big screen I
kind of envy him for that as for what
bothered me in this movie I know you
don't want things to bother you it's a
Mario movie but there are always things
I felt this movie cut short that which
makes a Mario game a Mario game which is
the platforming the action platforming
example there's a scene where they're
like okay we're at Point a we gotta get
to point B here we go then it cuts back
to them they're like okay we've arrived
at point B well my thought was I I'm
sure there's a whole journey to getting
here and that's really the spirit of a
Super Mario Brothers game there seemed
to be a movie that was more concerned
about the destination than the journey
and I feel like a Mario game is more
concerned with the journey than the
destination not that the movie doesn't
have action sequences the last act has
all of that it's actually kind of
awesome it's a lot it's fun it's within
the context and lore of the Super Mario
Brothers games and the power-ups that be
now finishing off my I know Less Fun
negative observations I got to address
something the movie did that I felt did
hurt it and that is separating Mario and
Luigi they do kind of a script flipping
here where Luigi's the one that gets
captured by Bowser so it's Mario Peach
and Toad that are on the adventure Peach
not getting captured and going on the
adventure totally fine on more than a
couple of occasions she has been in on
the action by not getting kidnapped
whatever but it was weird that they felt
someone still needed to get kidnapped so
we're gonna kidnap Luigi they use that
as the reason Mario goes on this
adventure but I don't think he needed it
there's enough Threat Level there it's
like Bowser is going to destroy the
Mushroom Kingdom maybe Mario or Luigi
would be like oh we just want to get
home but one of them could talk to the
other one and be like we should help we
need help because that's what Heroes do
and then they'll be like all right yeah
let's let's help this world out that
sounds like a good idea because we're
good guys I'd be totally fine with that
all this is to say I thought it was a
mistake separating Mario and Luigi
because Chris Pratt and Charlie Day are
amazing together the Mario and Luigi
Dynamic the Brotherly Love dynamic
between these two was actually kind of
incredible and the first 20 minutes or
so of setup is with them and then you
separate them yeah I had that feeling of
oh well Mario and Luigi need to you know
he needs to save his brother so the duo
can get back together but what
superseded that feeling what overrode
that was the feeling of yeah the movie
is a lot less now because they're
separated it would have been so much
better to keep them on screen together I
know Mario's had his solo Adventures
before without Luigi but in terms of
this movie and the setup for this film
the two were just too good together to
separate look in the end you're gonna
hear this word where people talk about
the Super Mario Brothers movie you're
gonna hear it's a cute movie because
it's true it is a cute movie it's
actually a really tough thing adapting a
Super Mario Brothers movie because Super
Mario fandom spans about well it's
nearly four decades now who do you aim
the movie towards this is a family film
it's a film for children absolutely it
hit its Mark in some spots had its flaws
in other spots funny it's a 90 minute
run time usually I feel like that's a
perfect run time for a family animated
film but if they kick that up to an hour
45 it felt like we could have gotten one
or two more action platforming sequences
that would have felt a little more like
a Mario Brothers game it's a fun family
time at the movies it's not as amazing
as you probably wanted to be but also on
the other hand it doesn't suck some of
the flaws aside I still had a fun time
in this one no alcohol required or
mushrooms you know whatever substance is
in the Mushroom Kingdom these days or so
the Super Mario Brothers movie have you
seen it what did you think about it
what's your favorite Super Mario
Brothers game that's a good question
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
Metroid is Ellen Ripley in an Iron Man
suit how is that not happened before